You requested an update of my rash and my hives. This person asked about this about six weeks ago. I still have it now approaching seven weeks. The right left shoulders and upper front upper chest mid to lower back.
Other areas diminished or stocked in general not as bad as it was in the past. Extremely itchy at night.
I experimented a little with stopping various protocols for a while.
Didn't seem to make a difference. Please note that I had breakouts of the past.
Over the last few years. Never this extreme though in past. I thought it was a skin fungus related to nail fungus. I have also usually appears as weather warms up.
Two which is true.
As this time as well. Thank you to try the right carc bold footpath or carcadena footpath.
I mentioned the right the rash to my oncologist wondering if related to the colon tumor he never answered but suggested that they restage is now retired.
And I'm getting a new oncologist with restage.
Next Tuesday arranged with my sister carpenter full blood panel. So I'd like to see those results on the full blood panel.
If you look at the CDC and you see an elevated eocidophil.
That's a segmentation of your white blood cells. So if you have an imbalance in your white blood cells, you might have normal white blood cell, but you have elevated eocidophiles.
That's a sign of an allergic reaction. So you're having some sort of allergic reaction because you can have hives and a ration and not be an allergic reaction.
So some sort of allergic reaction and typically you're thinking with elevated eocidophiles you're thinking of some sort of environmental allergy like sensitivity to something that you're wearing some chemical in the air.
So, you know, even pollen can give you that things like that. Those are possibilities.
It is possible that you have rash or hives related to cancer. Typically it's lymphoma that causes rash and hives and things.
And it's more so on the lower extremities, maybe on the extremity upper extremities a little bit.
Most of the time with lymphoma you'll get really, really itchy. I've had people that say I they found out they had lymphoma because they're so they had such bad rash that they were scratching and they even caused bleeding.
Finally went in and then had some blood tests and found that it was lymphoma.
It has been noted that other cancers can cause this as well. It's not, it's not completely certain why that can happen, what the issue is, but it's causing some imbalance in history levels of the skin.
And the other things that you could try are if you haven't tried like clear histamine scavenger or ABP1 assist those products might be helpful to calm things down and over the color antihistamine medication could help.
And I actually have that information in my book. I think it's a climatic climate. I mean, I don't remember the name, the brand name. It's actually an old antihistamine over the color antihistamine. I don't know if you can find it anymore, but this it's the same metabolic pathway that
that can be an off label use of a drug. So there were last week we talked about off label use of medication. Well, off label use of over the color antihistamines can actually calm down a tumor, calm down a cancer.
I don't know. Maybe this is the way God's kind of pushing you to try something like that. Maybe that's going to be a help with your colon cancer. You know, there really isn't a whole lot of negative side effects over the color antihistamines.
Gosh, I don't know. I think I would maybe give it a try. Maybe it's not even going to be for your rash. It's going to be for your colon cancer.